pierre laurin bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
ce matin sur rtl france alors
l'allemagne en attente d'un nouveau
chancelier olaf scholz est le favori
alors lui il prône pour une europe plus
forte pas question de remettre en
question la place de l'allemagne au sein
de l'otan
bref l'arrivée d'un nouveau chancelier
est ce que ça peut avoir un impact sur
les relations entre l'allemagne et la
russie
franchement dans le court terme non non
parce que tous les pays européens sont
dans le carcan d'une certaine manière de
l'union européenne qui a une politique
bien déterminer qui est profondément
contre la russie et donc il n'est pas
possible techniquement qu'il y ait des
changements rapidement peut-être à plus
long terme effectivement en fonctions du
nouveau chancelier
en fonction également de la coalition
électorale par exemple si la coalition
électorale comprend les verts il ne faut
s'attendre à aucun mais vraiment aucun
changement dans la mesure où les verts
sont profondes elle profondément anti
russe en revanche si il y a plus de
place à gauche la gauche est
traditionnellement en particulier un
parti minoritaire qui est d-link c'est à
dire la gauche justement est plutôt
pro-russe syli a également ce qui est
peu probable
une entrée de la fds c'est à dire
l'extrême droite
également sont plutôt favorables à la
russie mais tout ça c'est très très peu
probable ce qui est la constante depuis
des années c'est que la politique
allemand de sa ligne vis-à-vis de la
russie sur la position européenne et
particulièrement la position des pays de
l'est européen qui sont très anti russe
ce qui n'empêche pas d'ailleurs que les
relations économiques entre les deux
soit excellente parce que finalement
gala merkel est là elle a toujours
défendu à maintien de relations solides
avec le kremlin et vous le soulignez
l'allemagne qui a tout intérêt aussi à
conserver cette relation notamment à
bonnut économique bien sûr bien sûr
c'est l'économie qui prime tout mais il
faut voir les limites de la relation par
exemple sur le projet de gazoduc north
stream 2 l'allemagne a très bien joué
les états unis étaient profondément
contre parce que il envisageait de
vendre leur propre gaz naturel liquéfié
à l'allemagne plutôt que celle ci achète
le gaz russe elle a tenu tête et la
queue ni tête très fermement en revanche
sur un sujet comme le vaccin russe
spoutnik la chancelière allemande était
tout à fait favorable à ce que l'europe
donne en fallait les services sanitaires
européens donnent le feu vert à la
production et à la vente surtout de
spoutnik en europe l'envisagé même une
coproduction avec la russie et ça
c'était au mois de janvier février
dernier et puis tout s'est arrêté parce
que les européens ne vous ne veulent pas
du vaccin russe d'ailleurs je me permets
une petite parenthèse remarquer
qu'actuellement tous les vaccins à
l'exception des deux vaccins américains
sont déconsidérés il n'ya que seither et
moderna qui ont aujourd'hui le haut du
pavé les vaccins chinois sont
déconsidérés les vaccins russe n'est pas
admis astrazeneca est tombé dans les
oubliettes de l'histoire et il ne reste
donc plus que ça isère et moderna les
deux américains comme par hasard alors
le 20 août dernier pour revenir sur
cette relation trop miel à merkel et
vladimir poutine la chancelière
allemande s'était rendu en russie
c'était sa dernière rencontre avec
vladimir poutine comment qualifier leur
relation des points de vue opposés mais
en même temps un réel respect voulions
voit sur ces images dans le bouquet de
fleurs offert à angela merkel par
vladimir poutine
oui réel respect certainement parce que
même
honnêtement merkel aime bien la russie
elle est le lien d'alvès
par le russe elle aime la culture russe
en revanche ses relations avec poutine
ont été marqués dès le départ par dix
ont une
incidence fâcheuse c'est à dire que
merkel a une phobie des chiens et
vladimir poutine lors de leur première
rencontre à mouscou à laisser circuler
librement comme il le fait d'habitude
d'ailleurs son chien labrador crédou etc
mais la pauvre en gala merkel était
terrifiée et c'est ce mauvais point de
départ a certainement tordu un peu les
relations entre les deux les deux chefs
d'état ensemble le chef de gouvernement
a le chic je crois que les relations
auraient pu être bien meilleure ce qui
n'y avait pas eu cet incident de départ
ce qui est important en revanche c'est
que par la suite la dîmière poutine
s'est racheté en salle a fait une cour
très
disons très caractéristique de l'âme
russe disons à l'égard de dans gala
merkel alors à faire navalni
cyberattaques ong allemande renvoyé de
russie il ya eu des dossiers de tension
ces derniers mois aussi ces dernières
années entre les deux nations est ce que
ces dossiers pourraient affecter
durablement les relations entre ces deux
pays
c'est à dire que la sélection sur
l'occasion de faire un peu table rase
sur les incidents du passé je crois que
effectivement la sphère navalni qui a
été très importante au cours des
derniers mois a perdu beaucoup de son
acuité maintenant on ne parle
pratiquement plus de la vanne il purge
sa peine tout le monde a admis que cette
peine finalement n'était pas une
n'était que partiellement politiques qui
avaient des raisons claires pour que
navalni soit traité de la sorte par
ailleurs maintenant
en raison des ses financements et de ses
contacts avec l'étranger navalni n'est
plus à même de mener une campagne
politique ce fait à l'intérieur de la
russie donc ça c'est c'est en train de
se calmer il y aura forcément d'autres
incidents qui vont surgir parce que la
russophobie en allemagne en europe ne va
pas rester
inactive va continuer à se manifester de
différentes manières encore
imprévisibles mais en tout cas cela
faire navalni là elle est réellement
à mon avis de termini merci beaucoup
pierre l'oral pour votre analyse je le
rappelle vous êtes journaliste écrivain
spécialiste de la russie notamment